welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am fair and cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman today a lot
of the news recently obviously has been
focusing on crazy things Donald Trump is
doing it's been focusing on John McCain
we had another school shooting or not
school shooting excuse me mass shooting
recently but there is another major
story that too few have spoken about
recently and to their credit recently
CNN actually did mention it and that is
the number of children being murdered in
Yemen at the hands of essentially US
defense contractors the weapons the
bombs the missiles that are killing
these kids may be fired by countries
like Saudi Arabia but they're being
manufactured right here in the United
States Boeing Lockheed those groups are
making these weapons that are killing
children we've all seen the reports
three weeks ago
44 children killed on a school bus the
missile bomb whatever you want to call
it hit the school bus
killed 44 children do you know what
those children were doing on the bus
they were on their way back from a field
trip it was a celebratory field trip
because they had just finished their
summer classes so they were out doing
something nice for the day they had
they'd finished summer education and
they were celebrating
they were only way back from that
celebration they were killed by weapons
made right here in the United States by
United States defense contractors sold
to countries like Saudi Arabia who just
killed him just fired the missile didn't
care where it went didn't care who got
hit didn't care who died and we know
they didn't care because last week and
this is the one that CNN finally spoke
up against and mentioned on the air
twenty
children and four women were killed
again by weapons made here in the United
States while fleeing violence they were
trying to leave they were running for
their lives and we blew them up now
currently the United States is not
officially at war I mean we have not
signed any declaration of war against
any particular nation we do have our you
know alleged war on terror happening
right now but that is no excuse for any
of this the only people who are
benefiting in any way from these
bombings are US defense contractors they
make and market and sell death and
destruction that is what these products
are designed to do and we have no
problem as a country allowing them to
operate allowing them to build these
things to sell them to our alleged
allies countries like Saudi Arabia one
of the worst human rights abusers on the
planet but sure they're one of our
closest allies but if any other country
abuses human rights in any way we're one
of the first people there to tell them
that they're horrible people and that
they have to stop or else we're gonna do
something but not Saudi Arabia no we let
them get away with anything
and that is one of the reasons why this
story is so disgusting they are
indiscriminately bombing they're killing
school children young children toddlers
women people fleeing the violence there
is no excuse for that whatsoever you
can't say oops you missed we were trying
to hit a bad guy over here but we ended
up launching it at the school bus no I
don't buy that and we have a very real
problem here and the problem goes beyond
just the fact that we still consider
Saudi Arabia to be a friendly country
the problem is that we allow these
weapons manufacturers here in the u.s.
to dictate who our friends are you know
CNN again I have to bring them up
because
so weird that they actually talked about
this story and how horrible it was
because CNN more so than any other
network is one of the first ones to
promote any kind of conflict you see
commercials on those networks is CNN
MSNBC Fox News you see commercials for
Boeing and Lockheed why why are they
advertising their services on a cable
news network are you average viewer and
consumer going to go out and buy a
missile no but you got to control the
messaging and you control the messaging
by becoming a powerful advertiser on
that network yeah they know you're not
going to go buy an f-15 fighter jet but
as long as they pay a few million
dollars to a CNN or Fox or an MSNBC to
just have their ads running on there
that gives them power with the network
so that is why it was so shocking and
admirable finally for once for CNN to
finally bring up this atrocity that's
happening in Yemen to finally talk about
it and say this is too much this we this
is bad children any death is bad any
death is bad don't get me wrong on that
but the fact that they are actually
actively apparently targeting children
that is a war crime in Saudi Arabia
doesn't seem to have a problem
committing them and unfortunately here
in the United States we don't have a
problem with not calling them out on it
either